nous nous retrouvons à la piscine des
terrasses ou piscine baleine de monaco
pour une dernière séquence donc pour
cette émission consacrée entièrement à
l'association sportive de monaco est au
bilan de la fin du championnat nous
retrouvons avec un certain nombre
d'invités avec dallas liaison qui jouera
la coupe du monde avec l'équipe
d'algérie et qui a été champion avec
monaco c'est ça je vais participer au
bon moment pour la première année à une
coupe du monde
bon ben c'est toujours intéressant quand
même pour un footballeur et pour ma
première année fut champion de france je
peux être qu'heureux quoi il paraît que
vous êtes un joyeux lurons un joyeux
drille avec christophe certain nombre
d'autres a joué j'adore rigoler puis
surtout que bon ici et ça me chambrer
quoi c'est tout pourquoi je sais pas je
suis peut-être à ce joueur qui est bons
acquis par assez vite consolé sur les
bêtises des joueurs c'est pour ça qu'ils
aiment bien même allumé dernière que
vous ayez fait dernière pour l'aca la
dernière elle va arriver là alors je
vais arriver dans quelques instants sous
vos yeux puisque je crois que je sais
pas quelle sera la victime j'aurais
d'abord remercié avant de vous rendre
l'antenne le docteur campora gérard
banide et tous les joueurs de l'as
monaco nous avoir reçu chez eux
aujourd'hui
et notre confrère georges bertellotti
qui a largement contribué à ce que cette
émission et lieux et se déroule dans de
bonnes conditions alors la plaisance
parce que bon avec mes camarades
me récupérer
heureusement j'ai cru qu'il
un salut michel aulas